budget meals forbade lost of mushroom
you ain't gotta tell nobody that having
didn't know by see that what's up
everybody I'm David and I love cooking
whether it be for my friends or
especially from our girlfriend Amanda so
today I'm gonna try to make a steak
dinner for two for only fourteen dollars
it's gonna be a little tough I'm not
always the best bargain shopper but
we'll see if she can guess how much I
actually spent let's get shopping
well that was a little bit tough
I mean shopping on a budget isn't always
easy but I tried to make sure that I
could find some items on sales so we
could stay within our budget
we came out to just a little bit over 14
dollars and 33 cents that's not too bad
for a steak dinner for two
along with these items today we're gonna
be using some things that we always keep
in the tasty pantry we recommend that
you keep these as well they can often be
found in a lot of different recipes that
way your shopping list can be that much
shorter today we'll be using an olive
oil salt pepper and butter all right
let's start getting some of this stuff
out so I can start on our first recipe
alright so first we're gonna make a
double baked creamed spinach potato
creamed spinach
baked potato they both give me a steak
house Bob and why not just marry them
again the best of both worlds
so we're gonna split the potato and then
you'll want to put it flesh side down on
your parchment paper make sure that you
pierce the skin this will help the heat
to escape as it's baking now we're gonna
put it in the oven at about 400 degrees
for about 45 minutes or so until it's
easily pierced with a fork
alright so our potatoes are ready to go
I waited about 15 minutes until the pan
is cool to the touch so that we can work
with these bad boys now what you want to
do is grab a paring knife maybe or a
spoon and flesh out the inside of the
potato leaving about a quarter inch of
space
my girlfriend's a little bit better of a
bargain shopper than me so I know when
she sees all of this stuff she's gonna
think I spent like $50 that's the best
part you can have a really nice meal for
a great price point now we're gonna
scoop the insides into this bowl and
stuff potatoes are always something that
I love because you can grab a bunch of
different ingredients like the creamed
spinach or if you want to throw some
cheddar cheese or you know maybe some
mushrooms or something like that if you
want to make it a little fancier and
have a really delicious side they look
kind of elegant while still on a budget
you can dress it up with a lot of
different ingredients season it however
you want and they're pretty quick and
easy to make now
before I continue with the mixture
you're gonna want to put a little bit of
butter on the inside of your potato skin
when we put them back in the oven this
will make sure it gets a nice golden
brown it's really rich and crispy in a
little bit too much better never had
anybody's recipe now that we've got
these guys ready I'm gonna mince a
little garlic we want to make sure that
we cut this really finely if you
actually have your date already there
this one you can show off your knife
skills just put your hand across the top
look into their eyes let them know how
you making a nice little dinner for to
make sure you throw it off like that
when you go ahead and slide it all you
can use some gloves or something if you
need to but you want to make sure you
put a whole lot of love into the meal
I'm gonna add this to my mixture now
typically you might use some heavy cream
we decided to go with half in half
because it's a little bit cheaper and
again helped us hit that $14 price point
and now we're gonna add about three
tablespoons of butter and again if you
put a little bit extra ain't nothing to
worry about
we got our Parmesan cheese that is gonna
go amazing with the garlic just a little
look-look pinch of salt that day and now
we have some frozen spinach which is a
lot cheaper than fresh spinach but still
gives you the great flavor that you're
looking for you do want to make sure
since we're gonna be baking this that
you strain out any of the excess water
that you might have gotten while you
defrosted it so we'll just put it into a
little strainer here you can use the
back of a spatula a spoon or whatever
works just make sure you get all that
moisture out as much as you can now
we'll add this into our mixture kind of
mash it up a little more with this fork
so we can get a nice creamy filling this
smells really good
that minced garlic is gonna be perfect
that butter will give it a nice rich
flavor mm-hmm shingle bit we get mad at
me for at least two weeks after this I'm
gonna go ahead and spoon this mixture
into my potatoes you want to make a
little mound get it all the way in there
spread it evenly now we want to sprinkle
just a little bit more parmesan on top
so we can have a nice little crust
maybe a little generous winning just I
just let it fall like that don't be
afraid of it now let it fall okay now
we'll pop these back into the oven for
about 15 minutes or so or until it's
nice and golden brown on the top so keep
an eye on these we
cuz you don't want him to get too crispy
but you know we want to just warm them
up a little bit let that butter and
cream really heat up and get rich so we
can mix with that potato show all right
be right back all right guys now it's
time for my favorite part we're gonna
make the steak the main course I did a
little bit of research since we were
shopping on a budget and in some local
ads at my local grocery store I saw that
they had a nice tri-tip loin for only
399 a pound that's about 50% off than
the usual retail price so we really
scored here I'm gonna want to make sure
to heat up my pan properly cuz you
really want this to be super hot I'm
gonna put about a tablespoon of oil in
here just enough to kind of evenly cover
the bottom another reason that we chose
this cut is because it's tender it
doesn't require any marinating like a
lot of tougher cuts of meat and plus we
ain't got no money for no marinade this
is dollar dish so we're gonna go ahead
and just throw a little bit of salt and
a little bit of pepper but you want to
make sure that you're generous because
since we're only going to be seasoning
it right now this is the only chance you
have to add those flavors once we put it
into this hot pan it's gonna sear up
really nicely and we want to make sure
those flavors soak through this piece of
move all right so now I'm gonna grab
these gloves so I can move this steak a
little bit and make sure that I get a
nice even coating of seasoning again you
want to make sure that you kind of
overly salt this just a bit now we've
got some freshly cracked black pepper
just a little bit let the pepper nasaw
dance together a little bit you know I'm
sorry now we're gonna cook this for
about two to three minutes on each side
and that's a good sound that smells
great
now you want to make sure not to disturb
it too much so that we can make sure it
gets that nice even brown color on each
side so for a piece of meat this thick
we're probably looking at about nine to
ten minutes let's go ahead and check on
this color a little bit all right it's
looking really good just about ready for
a turn but my girlfriend loves baked
potatoes so I know she's gonna love this
meal I mean the creamed spinach filling
again is gonna give it just a nice rich
flavor and I think the extra butter that
I put in is gonna provide the love we're
looking for now we're gonna turn this
guy on that last side and again just
leave it there
let it get nice and brown that color is
beautiful we're making this about a
medium-rare to medium well but again you
can leave it for a few more minutes
depending on your taste this is looking
pretty good so now that we've got our
last side all taken care of
we're gonna turn down the heat just a
little bit we're gonna bake this with a
butter to again just give it more of a
rich flavor make this steak taste even
more amazing just kind of run that
butter through the pan let it catch all
the rest of the flavor from that nice
pan sear we just want to cover this
steak and some nice melted butter now
the butter starting to get brown so you
want to take it out after that all right
now we're gonna go ahead and let this
rest for about 15 minutes so that we can
lock all those juices in and it won't
dry out when we slice the tri-tip and
plate it in just a little bit now I
wanted to make this a little bit more
fancy so I'm gonna whip up a little
mushroom sauce that we can drizzle over
it when we play I'm gonna go grab these
ingredients and I'll be right back to
show you how we turn this from a
two-star to a four-star meal alright
everybody now that I've got all my
ingredients laid out we can make this
far mushroom sauce just really gonna
step it up a little bit and again just
deal with some of the drizzle on there
make it look real fancy so what I'm
gonna do it set this pan to about a
medium heat and I went ahead and scooped
out all of the oil except for about 1
tablespoon you're not gonna need too
much you want to go ahead and throw your
mushrooms in there we're gonna cook
these about 5 to 7 minutes until they're
nice and soft so you can just get a
little bit of oil on those all right now
while that's going I'm gonna mince up a
little bit of garlic 2 or 3 cloves for
this one because I like garlic you know
that's up to you again I'm gonna go in a
nice fine chop here that should just
about do it I'm gonna wait until my
mushrooms get a little softer and then
we'll throw them in these will get a
nice brown color saute really nicely
soften up and they'll look perfect with
that steak that we got about to make me
a little cookbook budget meals for babe
now this is gonna take about five to
seven minutes so you definitely want to
take your time here and make sure that
you're putting the love into the meal
don't want to rush that just take your
time let the mushrooms get happy that
the oils soaked on in there and let that
steam come together to make a nice
lovely little steak dinner for two
these are looking perfect nice and soft
we've got a nice golden brown color on
them so we're gonna go ahead and add in
this garlic
a little bit of salt that's all you need
right there just about three piles
you're gonna be good to go add this beef
stock and we only spent half a dollar so
you're gonna pour that on in there and
just continue to mix it lightly and let
that reduce by about half now these were
pre-sliced and the manager special so
not only did I save money I save time
which is definitely gonna be the name of
the game when you're trying to make it
dinner for two makes it easy maybe you
had work that day you can still come
home and make this delicious meal
without taking up too much time now it's
reduced down by about 50% we've got a
nice thin layer of that beef stock
cooking up with that garlic in those
mushrooms so what I'm gonna do is reduce
the heat to low and slowly mix in this
half in half now again this is an
ingredient we had in our other recipe
we're going to be able to use it for
both and stir it as you pour so it can
thicken up now you want to go ahead and
let this thicken up for about five to
seven minutes stir it every so often
kind of let all those flavors come
together sauce is ready so I'm gonna
turn that off now we're gonna go ahead
and slice this beautiful steak and you
want to try to make sure to keep those
slices about 1/2 inch apart and to
always cut against the grain you see
that beautiful color we got in there
from that pan sear all of those juices
locked in because we gave it that proper
rest time see if I can make something
pinterest worthy now I wasn't
necessarily able to make every cut
beautiful so you can just go into
sampling pieces before you get a ride
you know so for plating we're gonna go
ahead and try to take two to three
slices of this
and then I'm gonna put something this
nice mushroom sauce on top now we've got
that twice baked creamed spinach potato
man is almost here I'm gonna go ahead
and plate mine now it's time to go grab
Amanda and see what she thinks
hopefully I was able to pull this off
and make it taste like a professional
steak dinner all right open your eyes
what do you think wow that looks good
you're not trying to do my thang so what
we have here for you is a tri-tip anoi
covered in a mushroom cream sauce and I
went ahead and threw in a twice-baked
creamed spinach potato at this point I
can do is let you taste it so you see
what your thing okay you see the face I
definitely like a really great
restaurant Claudia you haven't she said
Michelin star on the way I'm gonna go
and see what you think about this
creamed spinach twice baked potato this
looks so bad
cream before you go-go mm-hmm okay you
see what I did what I was doing when I
did it in there that was on purpose now
we got that nice even color we got a
nice crisp over in the bottoms crispy
the tops crispy like you know I brush
the butter on here I wasn't gonna just
put him in that's really good
how much you think I spent on all of
these ingredients I would say spent 30
ish for the first time in quite a long
time she's wrong and I'm right
I only spent 14 dollars and 33 cents and
everything I don't know if I'll always
be able to stay within the budget like I
should but we'll see if I can try to you
know take after you and find some deals
from that one I mean as long as it
tastes like that I'd be happy with
however much you spend to be honest at
this point I think it's time for me to
finish this available thank you baby
where's your work that's it enough I'll
catch you guys later
[Music]
[Music]
you